would you recommend the military to
young men today
i'm glad you asked that question because
you and rolo have helped me so so much
and the reason i'm on this program say
thank you to you and rallo thank you
appreciate it because what happened to
me was you know i was i don't think i
was alpha but i was a marine pilot i was
pretty much an
and then i got married to a great woman
still married to her but i turned into a
big fat beta
and i was very happily married man i
never cheated on my wife and all that
and i realized that was a big mistake
not not cheating i mean you know i don't
cheat
even on my taxes i pay no taxes but i
don't cheat but anyway um
i became a big fat beta yeah and so when
my wife left me as you guys talk about
what 80 percent are initiated by the
woman correct and it was like taking a
shotgun blast right in the chest with
her lovers don't march
and then so my friend george gammon gave
me rollo's book
and then he told me to watch you on
because he drives a mclaren like you do
and so i'm watching you guys you guys
are on to it i mean you guys have a
message that's worth talking about
because as you guys say testosterone
levels are going down
and as a marine you know i'm not lbgt
i'm a man i like women if you want you
want to have sex with a man that's your
private property it's not mine i don't
give a
but what you guys talk about is
essential
and you know i i asked to come on your
program just to validate what you're
saying
we have too many guys who aren't men
anymore there's no money they have no
money no sex no power yeah no sex no
power
yeah tragedy money sucks power yeah
let's let's um let's cover that too but
i want to go back to the uh question
about would you recommend the military
to men today because i mean the military
today is a lot different than the
military that you joined back in the day
yeah they're not they they now have you
know black lives matter training and all
that stuff inside of it
there's a uh victor davis hanson you
know he did a thing about patent it's
it's i think it's for hillsdale college
and people should study patent because
that guy was a wild man
and
but he got pounded because eisenhower
and those guys were kind of
my one of my best friends the three star
general marine you know
and and he fought doesn't storm he
fought in vietnam he did all this he
says but too many generals today are
bunker bunnies
you know they don't go on the front line
and patton was a frontline guy
and so the difference in mindset so
against victor davis handsome he talks
about george patton and i think every
man should listen to patton what what
patent was like is there a um is there a
piece of material that you'd recommend
most is there a book is there a
documentary or anything or no it's it's
victor davis hanson on youtube he spoke
to hillsdale college okay but he did
this whole um
report on patent
and patton was kind of my hero too
because like i said he
he was gonna he wanted to take on russia
and eisenhower and the boys that wanted
to take him take russia you know patent
all they remember a patent for was
slapping those
people in the hospital which you should
have done
but he was a rich guy
he's kind of like a trump even the same
same kind of energy
so it's not not whether you're rich or
poor it's your spirit you come out with
so patton was kind of my hero my aunt my
aunt
was a prima ballerina of paris
and she fought for the french
underground so when i was at school in
new york at king's point
she used to talk to me about patton also
the guy was a real stud
but but the but the political generals
like eisenhower and those guys
you know they get the glory but the guys
like patton are on the front line and
i'd rather be on the front line so
that's the long answer to the military i
am glad i went
i am really really glad but not
everybody should go
yeah
i'm i'm not um i mean uh
i have guys that that have been in the
military that are that are asking
questions about
you know do you think it's a good place
to spend some time and i think it i mean
i see the value in the discipline and i
see the value in the camaraderie and i
see the value in um you know the grit
that i suppose that every guy should
still be learning there
but um
there's just a lot like i've got a guy
that i was coaching a couple years ago
that was a naval officer and and he was
telling me all these stories of all the
political nonsense that he was dealing
with on the boat and
female officers and the drama and it's
just like all the stuff back and forth
and it's like you know he's on a
trajectory to go start his own business
and
the military doesn't offer him
anything
that would be useful to his future so i
mean we put a plan together to basically
you know put an exit strategy out
because i mean when the writing's on the
wall and you see it then it's just like
okay you know enough's enough we have to
accept this and surrender that this is
the environment that we're in today
we're not going to change it by
protesting or complaining to a
a ceo right
um
had this you saw what happened in
afghanistan right yeah yeah yeah they
just that was like
that was absolute treason that was
foreign lieutenant colonel who
criticized the joint chiefs of staff
yeah they should put the joint chiefs of
staff and biden in jail for what
happened in afghanistan that was treated
yeah but they put this marine lieutenant
colonel in jail
what is wrong with this country
yeah that was um i don't know how many
years that war was but it's like they
basically spent all that time and money
in afghanistan and all these men lost
their lives to basically replace the
taliban with the taliban that's that's
what they ended up with
um but what are you gonna do um
yeah the military is a interesting
conversation these days especially you
know with the topics around uh russia
and china and what's going on between
you know china and taiwan right now and
uh you know how that's going to affect
things here
you